thanks so much so just quickly Eddie
Hartman I'm going to have a quick agenda
then we're going to do the interview
this is legalzoom for people who haven't
been there for our first ten years I
think most of us know us for these
products here as Victor was saying or
sorry it's kevin was saying we do you
know about one in four new companies in
states like California we do double
digits in other areas like trademarks we
do about one in six nonprofits start
through us very fortunate that way but
these days we were moving into services
so our new fastest growing and almost
our largest product is actually legal
advice we're sort of moving up the
chamber before I talk to you about that
we're very fortunate about seventy
percent of Americans know the name
legalzoom the next highest recognition
brand in the legal space is Craig and
fish which you may know is the law firm
from ally mcbeal that gets about a five
percent name recognition below that it's
Skadden Arps with about two percent so
it's seventy percent we're very happy we
want to go further than that but we're
pleased about a little more than two
million Americans have used us that's
more than live in Vermont Maine and you
know we ruthlessly metric ourselves on a
quality standard called Net Promoter
Score wtr willingness to a first score
you made some of you may know this
methodology but we're roughly the same
as Apple or Southwest in terms of
customer satisfaction we're very pleased
about that as well just clear up any
confusion yes it's the same company as
Robert Shapiro the day that Robert
Shapiro joined the company I called my
mom and I said mom you're never going to
believe it but Robert Shapiro is joining
legalzoom and my mom said my dentist so
we my co-founders Brian Lou has left to
start an amazing beverage company called
zenifi i highly encourage you to drink
zenifi not just because I'm an investor
but because it's awesome it's like the
anti red bullets it makes you you know
not drowsy but very focused and brian
lee left to start a company first with
her and then with her for while we were
joking that unless you had a sex tape
you couldn't start a company with brian
lee but then he that's Brian right there
he started a company with jessica alba
called honest which many of you know if
you have a chance to trade up from look
at Jessica now look at me now look at
Jessica now look at me yeah so good good
trade Brian from New Jersey which
science has proven is the best state in
the Indonesia I don't if you know that's
actually scientifically true my dad is a
physicist I was trained as a computer
scientist at Yale University BS computer
science very proud of that program ah my
friends that I started the business with
we're both lawyers and I think they
imagined that it would be something like
this and then it turned out to be like
that and then sort of like that and then
everyone in the internet space at the
end of the 90s was like this and we were
dumb I mean like not not bright people I
mean all these really smart lawyers were
you know desperately unhappy at their
jobs so we got together we started the
company this are this is an article by
the way from Business Insider wish Henry
was still there because I could point
out to him that if you're founded in
nineteen ninety nine in 2012 you should
not still be a hot start up what can I
tell you I guess we are so a lot of
people think that I'm anti lawyer I'm
going to be talking to you just briefly
about the problems with law I am not
anti lawyer I became a lawyer after
starting the company without going to
law school I did I did the hard like the
Abraham Lincoln method of reading for
the bar spent four years sat for the bar
passed the bar I'm a lawyer now I named
my son my first son I named in Sderot
after Clarence Darrow I deeply believe
in lawyers I think the reason that I'm
still at the company is I'm the zealot I
believe that I believe in law I believe
in a system of law I believe people
should have access to law to make their
lives better and I think it's not
happening right now which is what I want
to talk to you about so I think law was
broken
I don't mean in a Martin Luther King
sense you know what I mean you're in
jail and you can't get a lawyer I think
it's far more mundane and far more
pervasive I think it affects all of us I
think you know everybody in this room
has signed a contract without reading it
right companies tend not to do that
people who can afford it people that
have access to law tend to use it they
tend to review contracts but we don't
because it's out of our reach right so
the ABA says only fifteen percent of
Americans who have a legal problem seek
the help of a lawyer if only fifteen
percent of Americans with a serious
medical problem sought the help of a
doctor we would say there's a real
problem and it's down it's half since 92
it's fallen by half so you know that
that's my sort of first proof point
let's look at the average hourly rate
$285 think about it can you name
something that you pay more than a
hundred dollars an hour for in your life
right now that's not insured more than
200 otters an hour for and by the way
this is the median national rate in New
York City the hourly rate for a lawyer
is I think $25,000 or something like
that but it's the point is there is
probably nothing in the average
Americans life where they are asked to
pay more than a hundred dollars an hour
so you'd think well the price has got to
come down particularly with unemployment
going up and up and up among lawyers but
it's not there's this terrible
disequilibrium why aren't we you know
everybody's taking basic economics it's
supposed to get equilibrium it's going
to hit a clearing price at some point
it's not it's not so why why are people
not consuming why do only fifteen
percent of Americans seek to help of a
lawyer when they have a serious legal
problem it's not just price there are a
lot of things that are wrong if you are
faced with a serious legal problem you
don't know what the process is you don't
know what the quality of a lawyer is
going to be right you don't know you
probably call a friend and say can you
give me the name of a good lawyer the
lawyer that you use for your divorce do
they also do real estate closings
because I need a lawyer you know is that
going to be good it's hard saying by the
way prices on the is on the decline as a
factor that people care about this is
going from twenty twelve to twenty
thirteen people care less and less about
price more about other factors so
not having disability into the quality
of the lawyer not having visibility into
what the process is how long is it going
to take how difficult is this thing
going to be and of course price you told
me what the hourly rate was how many
hours how long will this thing take you
don't know these things I see people
nodding yeah absolutely so there's also
no no brands what are the big names in
law other than us there aren't any like
I told you Alec me ally mcbeal that's
the next best name and it's been off the
air for a damn long time so there aren't
the sort of things that promote
consumption and I want to tell you this
is not by accident we have a guild
system of law right now I'm going to be
talking about this a little bit more
sure in the interview but right now you
if you if you're in trouble you'll be
defended by a member of the skilled
you'll be prosecuted by member this
guilty the case will be decided by
member this guild the laws that you'll
be tried under will generally have been
formulated and passed by members of this
guilt so it's a very very powerful thing
and important to understand they
introduce friction into the system that
generates that lack of equilibrium what
am I talking about lawyers have
restrictions on what they can say about
how good they are there restrictions on
calling himself a specialist or
advertising so when I say you know you
don't have visibility into the quality
of the lawyers it's not by accident you
have to get licensed on a state-by-state
basis what does this mean if you're a
doctor in California and you go to
Nevada you're still a doctor if you're a
doctor if it serves your lawyer in
California and you go into Nevada you're
not a lawyer anymore if you're a lawyer
in New York and you go into New Jersey
you're not a lawyer anymore and they've
criminalized the unauthorized practice
of law so that lawyer who goes from New
York into New Jersey and practices law
there can be put into jail for up to a
year if I go to the drugstore and get a
flu shot that's great the legal
equivalent which might be selecting a
form for me it's a felony in Florida
it's punishable by up to a year in
California New York New Jersey a lot of
different places so you know I think
that's absolutely crazy and maybe worst
of all generally when we face a large
problem in America we turn to experts we
talked to a great technologist
industrialists people who know process
law firms cannot
those sorts of professionals because
they cannot reward them they can't give
them options or stock or anything like
that in a law firm law firms are not
able to give any sort of equity
ownership so you know I'm just going to
flip through these pretty quickly but
because states give a monopoly to
lawyers over the practice of law because
they give a monopoly to this guild
prices are runaway people with better
knowledge than me like the State Bar of
Illinois say it's a monopoly and now I'm
going to show you a company called
silver flume it's actually website not a
company called silver flew silver flame
is a fantastic website that competes
directly with my company legalzoom they
do corporations LLC's and more in the
state of Nevada and even though they are
a direct competitor I will tell you this
is a beautiful website it is an amazing
piece of technology it is fantastic and
not only that it was done by the
democratically elected secretary of
state of the state of Nevada ross miller
he's the one who put this up and why am
i showing this to you because ross
miller again the secretary of state for
nevada the man in charge of running
businesses in the state of nevada and
certifying them the guy who was elected
by the people in Nevada was sued by his
State Bar and had to change this website
so i think it's no you no coincidence
that people look at the legal industry
as a protectionist guild that has
created an unworkable situation and law
firms contribute to this by having a
focus on profits per partner and not
taking this need for change very
seriously and again you America we
Americans have given a monopoly to a
guild that instead of thinking about our
best interest measures itself by profits
per partner so other countries have
figured this out so in England 2003
there was a big study the Clemente study
which said the average Briton doesn't
have access to a good lawyer they passed
the law in 2007 saying let's turn it
into a more businesslike structure let's
allow public investment into law firms
in 2009 Australia says that's a great
idea let's do the same thing a very very
small company called Slater and Gordon
decides will be a law firm we're not run
by lawyers but very smart businessmen
today it's by most estimates the sixth
largest law firm in the world having
bought up a lot of other
European and British law firms what's
the result people said we get more value
for money forty four to forty five
percent increase in things like value
and meanwhile in the ABA is still saying
we need a better model we need to change
but where are the active steps to change
things so you know this is a great paper
i can send it to anyone who wants to I
don't think law is going to die just
needs to reorganize we think itself
change what it's doing this is an
amazing coat my birthday is September
fifth if anyone wants to get me a
present this code is hand-stitched it is
bespoke you can pass it down it's nine
thousand dollars and i'll give you my
measurements after this all over but
this is a coat that i bought my daughter
when we went to texas and discovered
that in December's actually really cold
in Texas that was nineteen dollars from
target no one is going to say that the
object on the right is not a coat
everyday people say that the things that
we do at legalzoom are not law because
it is mass-produced because it is meant
to an industrial standard and I think we
need to change the way that we think
about that we need to change the idea of
what law is and how we can access it we
need to look at what they're doing in
other professions so we need to say you
know what you should be able to get the
legal equivalent of a flu shot at your
local drugstore there should be lower
levels of professionals were able to
engage with lawyers in a better way we
need to look at the UK and say maybe we
ought to have equity investment in law
firms maybe want to have publicly traded
law firms that actually invest in
technology and process because after all
if you're judged based on the number of
hours that you work why would you work
fewer hours and finally I to look at the
whole consumer solution if you're just a
law firm and all you do is say
bankruptcy and a person comes to you in
financial distress you're going to put
them in a bankruptcy but maybe that's
not what they need maybe they need a
more nuanced solution you know maybe you
can offer them other things a company
can do that a law firm will only give
you the legal remedy every single time
so just to conclude I think this is a
change that is coming you cannot have a
system where only fifteen percent
people are getting their leads their
needs met by the system I think
especially as we see the UK Australia
and now Canada by the way all start to
say we've got to change this technology
does not look at Geographic borders and
this change is going to come I think
it's more of a question should we do it
in a regulated way where we can manage
the change or we just going to let the
roof cave in and that's it so Eddie
maybe we can pick up where you left off
which is this question of unauthorized
practice of the law which LegalZoom is
has had to contend with I think you had
a run where you had 12 depositions in
three months and but here we are legal
zooms operating in all 50 states you're
competing fiercely with the state of
Nevada and Nevada have you won or is
there more work to do well i think that
there's a lot more work to do a one of
the most chilling things that we see
again and again is that people can't
even define what you pls that's
unauthorized practice of law of course
so it's a felony but no one can tell me
how it's defined which raises certain
problems I was told by a regulator who I
can't name that in his state spell
correct on a legal document would be
found to be the unauthorized practice of
law to which I said so you know Bill
Gates coming in here any time soon and
he said now we're not we're not bringing
in Microsoft just you Eddie so yeah but
it's a real thing to have a felony
without a definition behind it in state
of New Jersey fourth-degree crime but
again carries a jail sentence and you
don't know how its defined and there
there's been a development on this front
in the last three months or so this case
from the Supreme Court North Carolina
State Board of dental examiners the FTC
and this was an antitrust case against a
state licensing board that sent these
nasty grams to health spas when they got
involved in teeth whitening saying that
that was the practice of Dentistry
legals in wrote an amicus brief to the
court in that case and the court ended
up
riding with legalism you want to talk a
little bit about that sure yeah i mean
i'd like to think that the court sided
with fairness but so basically what
North Carolina said in a layman's
nutshell is hey we sometimes have to
give professionals a monopoly on
practice like we have to give doctors a
monopoly on the practice of medicine
okay but wait a second if you're taking
that monopoly and also telling me where
it ends that's not cool anymore we're
going to have to have democratically
elected officials overseeing this and if
you don't then you're subject to
antitrust does this have a holding for
the State Bar's I think it absolutely
does I think you know too long we've
just put up with a not merely granting a
set of interested market participants a
monopoly over practice but also the
right to say where that monopoly starts
and stops and I think you know the
Supreme Court said well that's just that
just can't continue so yeah from now on
with the holding is in lusty unless
these these regulatory bodies want to
face antitrust charges they're going to
have to have oversight by an actively
involved nan market participant that's
been democratically elected I think
something all of us here when we
listened to you we see your presentation
is tremendous amount of passion about
this not just for building a business
but for democratizing access to justice
and I imagine that must be something a
sense of mission and culture that
pervades legalzoom and I wonder if this
is part of this sort of core DNA that
you started with in 2000-2001 or how
these culture you know and values came
about in the company I think for my
partners they were there all along I had
a conversion moment for sure I mean when
we first started talking about the
business and it was Brian Lou by the way
who came in and said I know what we can
do and describe what I think is a lot of
Legal Zoom today I had like people seen
the movie The Blues Brothers that moment
you know I have seen the light I was
like what instead of selling dog food
online and doing yet another
drugstore.com online here's something
that people need they don't know how to
find you not pay shipping costs for a
legal document I
like information is an ideal partner to
the Internet wow this is it this is what
I've been waiting for but I didn't get
it I really I guys I still saw it as a
commodity like oh well I can go from
trying to help people sell maternity
coat or which literally was a client of
mine was trying to sell maternity coat
or and thought that pregnant women buy
maternity coat or by the way for an
entire year until i pointed out so
you're not really pregnant for a whole
year it story for another day the point
is i said wow this is you know there's a
perfect thing this is something people
genuinely need but i really just saw it
as a commodity it wasn't all it wasn't
until i actually had to hand deliver
some documents in our early days which i
used to do hand delivering a living well
to somebody who's about to go into an
operation and they're not sure if
they're going to make it or not and is
in the kind of financial distress where
they couldn't afford a lawyer because
they can't pay 325 dollars an hour which
is the median in LA County it's a real
thing when you see a parent who doesn't
know if they're going to live or die and
had to tell their kids I'm going to say
goodbye because I don't know if I'm
going to make it through the surgery and
you give them the document that's going
to give them some peace of mind it's
pretty significant when you see people
start businesses and you know what
they're going going through sorry you
know they're you know that they're
emptying out their savings leaving their
job trying to start something their
families depending upon them and you're
helping them with that they don't pay a
lawyer that they can get it done through
legal soup really really meaningful
stuff and changes how you think about it
you're not just selling a selling a
bicycle or something you're selling
something that has huge meaning way
beyond the dollars to a person's life
and it absolutely changed how I thought
of a company in the business yeah and
you talk about it not just being a
commodity and I think that's probably
true in two respects one is it's not
just a commodity like steel is something
incredibly personal to people but the
other is that it's not just uniform
there's a sort of wide variety of
quality and that sort of dovetails with
your comment that you're now working
more and more with lawyers right you
guys disclose that in the course of 2011
you went from twelve percent of your
revenue from subscriptions to legal
services up to twenty-four percent who
knows maybe that's forty percent by now
can you talk a little bit about how you
grew that business so fast and just how
that business works
sure uh again I am rabidly pro lawyer in
fact I think a lot of what I want to do
is open lawyers eyes to the idea that if
they could simply ship the way that they
do business that eighty-five percent of
people who are unserved would come to
them and not only that a massive
financial opportunity if fifteen percent
of the market right now represents a
hundred billion dollars which is our
best estimate what is the remaining
eighty-five percent that's completely
untapped and beyond the financial impact
imagine the huge social good of giving
people legal services that they can
afford when right now they're you know
at the mercy of larger corporations
which is something I know that you're
working on as well but yeah the the fact
is there are a lot of things you cannot
do without a lawyer and we would never
try to so the question for us has been
how can you give people quality help
where they live how can you give person
a divorce lawyer that they can afford
how can you give people person who
actually go into court with them that's
something you can't really do through a
centralized website but people
absolutely desperately need so yeah more
and more we've been trying to work
flexibly with lawyers legal plans are a
great start we have ideas of other ways
that we can do it as well some of which
we've commented on publicly and and when
you talk about that early customer of
yours in LA County looking at 325
dollars an hour yeah to do that living
wills going into the operation obviously
the 325 dollars number is a big number
but then there's the mystery as to how
many hours this is going to be and that
kind of gets us into this world of
unbundled services which we're seeing
more and more of I think priority legal
is here in the audience today which is
focused on selling on bundled services
and I wonder how you think about that
marketplace evolving yeah i mean i think
is fantastic i think priorities great
and I think anyone who's trying to find
new and more flexible ways to deliver
legal services and try to fight that
non-consumption i think is fantastic
awesome well maybe we can talk about
something that's universal to at least
all the investors and investees who
kevin identified at the beginning of the
talk which is this question of how an
entrepreneur should choose an investor
and for a lot of us who are starting
businesses now
both because of technical solutions like
amazon web services but also legal
solutions like LegalZoom we don't
necessarily have huge upfront
procurement costs we don't necessarily
have to raise money at all and so it
becomes a question of which species are
going to add value as mentors which are
going to add value through relationships
or other sorts of support and I
certainly know some of your investors
have been really value additive to you
and I wonder which which ones you really
rely on right you know um actually Steve
Herrick who is Timothy Dwight 93 he said
you know the business of selling money
which is the business of being a banker
is tough because money is generally
fungible but you know the right the
right investor makes such a difference
and it's not just I think what you think
of when you're an entrepreneur which is
sort of that Good Housekeeping Seal of
Approval like wow I'm an adult look you
know Sequoia gave me money or whomever
it's it's much more of a philosophy are
they going to give you great guidance at
the board level do they know how to work
with you to expand and grow are there
are their aims the same as your aims and
yeah and in in in case of IBP polaris
kleiner perkins premiera he's been great
partners to us who have introduced us to
opportunities we wouldn't have had but i
think more importantly give us amazing
advice because you know for most
entrepreneurs it's their first maybe
second or third time running a company
so often investors have seen a variety
of situations and can really counsel
them and you mentioned premiera and in
2012 you guys decided to partner with
premier rather than going public but you
think back to 2001 when you're getting
started it seemed like the the greatest
marker of success in the startup world
was having an IPO and times have really
changed and partly through funds like
137 ventures which helped you know early
employees get liquidity right more
companies are choosing to stay private
so maybe you want to talk about that for
a second and then maybe Kevin Kevin do I
want to talk about that I want to talk
about a talk about it how about I did
this we'll talk about it talk about a
really crusher I think at the end of the
90s uh I had a lot of friends who were
paper billionaires you know like
everybody was going public it was pretty
great you could raise 60 million off a
napkin
and it was kind of dumb it didn't make
much sense I really like what I'm doing
I like getting up in the morning and
saying I'm helping people I'm helping
people more and more I'm changing in an
industry that's ossified over the last
250 years the the public non-public
event isn't that meaningful for me it's
great to have a capital partner in
premiera who allows us to do what we
want to do and achieve our mission and I
think that's what people should look for
yet feels great to go public great I'm
sure you know but that if that's your
goal maybe rethink why you went into it
in the first place cool I'm gonna ask a
question too you've grown legalzoom as
you mentioned from like you and a couple
of friends but the idea to you know with
15 years of experience and how many
people do you have in your offices now
between 800 and a thousand you have
eight hundred thousand employees in
Glendale and nationally so like what one
piece of advice or a couple peers would
you give to other entrepreneurs who are
you know not just beyond the I have an
idea phase but to this growth phase like
what are some of the key things what
you've had to to do or realize well you
know I'll give you two if that's okay um
because ones like a nice friendly piece
of advice in the others like a real dick
all right give us the nights when
Heather gannis and the dog i'll give you
the bad one first there are going to be
people when you're first starting who
will bleed and die for you and work
nights and just be amazing amazing
amazing and you know what unfortunately
they will not be able to grow with the
company so get ready for hard choices
understand that the people that you work
with are like your brothers and arms or
sisters and arms but aren't they're not
actually you're going to have to make
hard choices about some of the people at
some point and get ready for it think
about it think about the people that
you're starting with and make sure that
they're people that you're just
incredibly impressed with because even
there you're going to have to make some
choices down the road there's a reason
that Brian Lee left you know as
legalzoom ramped up it wasn't the right
company for him anymore and look at him
he's doing amazing but I won't say that
that period where we were thinking about
things was an easy one for any of us and
so that that's the that's the real like
piece of advice is you know get ready to
have to be a little bit ruthless and how
you deal with people who stood by you
and supported you the nicer piece of
advice is this a lot of people say focus
on the product focus on the consumer
experience focus on the consumer focus
on the consumer it's real that's that's
not [ __ ] that actually will grow
your company if you really really really
relentlessly think about what is it that
the consumer wants you'll find these
insights that will shock you and your
consumer will tell you how come you
didn't know that and they will unlock
value and allow you to defeat your
competition because your competition
probably isn't thinking that way so
those are the two things that have
enabled us to grow is that an amazing
job letting you know anyone with the
idea for start-up help out with the
various legal services very awesome for
a lot of folks to to be able to use that
and then young you're also helping folks
out to in a similar vein with your
startup and talk about that sure so
David is building software to help you
resolve problems with either customer
service or billing or your products that
you get here I had a problem with
customer service or billing with their
you know Elektra electricity garbage ok
yeah ok yeah maybe one day electricity
and garbage do but but for now with your
your cable and your cell phone company
and so cable and cell phone who's that
pounds with a cable the cell phone bill
raise your hand yeah more ok these were
what was mentioned earlier the the sort
of contracts you've probably signed but
haven't read and we're launching a
private alpha today for New Yorkers and
so if you want to sign up for the
private alpha you can go to send David
calm and you built this company while
you were in law school or after you
graduated yeah I mean law school gave me
a good chance to sort of see the
question of consumer rights from 360
degrees so whether it's law journals or
law firms or legal aid clinics kind of
seeing the impact of this problem and
for me you know what I realized is that
so much of the service area this problem
is begging for best practices from
Silicon Valley to be applied to it and
so what I've been thinking about since
law school the last
is how to go about that Kevin I I just
want to add you know this is johns johns
company is a living embodiment of what I
say when I say that access to justice
isn't a Martin Luther King I'm in prison
kind of thing it's you not being able to
have any say in how you deal with large
companies because the class-action
system as we all know has become
completely ineffectual it's it's saying
no no we're going to find technology to
find a different way to take law and
bring a large group of people together
and actually get the things that you are
supposed to have you know and i think
the David's going to be an amazing
amazing company well that means a lot to
to come from you Eddie and I guess just
on eddies point about class actions to
flesh that out a little bit how many of
you have ever gotten in an email or a
letter that you might be entitled to
something because of some class action
so maybe about two-thirds of you and
then maybe I asked how many of you
actually jump through all the hoops to
claim what you were entitled to for the
five bucks so one two three four so
maybe about 20 or fifteen to twenty
percent of the people who first raised
their hands so this definitely must be a
Yale audience a lot of type-a
personalities in the room because that's
that's often actually better better than
the average and so that there were
limitations to to the efficacy of class
actions but really that's sort of an
academic point now because over the last
four years the Supreme Court has made
very clear that when a corporation puts
a term in your contract those contracts
we talked about that we don't read that
says you may not bring a class action or
participate in one or benefit from one
that that is valid and binding under
federal law so you can have academic
debates about the value of class actions
and their glory days but they're simply
not around for these sorts of issues
anymore let's open up to questions from
the audience who has questions
yeah hello all right so you talked about
you know class actions being ineffectual
but how do you define class action in
the fact that this isn't sure yeah so
under the rules of federal courts
there's this rule 23 which sort of sets
out a specific mechanism for how class
actions can proceed and there are a
bunch of requirements but three of the
requirements are that there have to be a
bunch of people and they all have to
have been hurt in the same way by the
same entity and so even in the kind of
hay day of class actions unless all of
those characteristics lined up it wasn't
going to be available when these
consumer contracts say you may not bring
in class action they're referring to
either that type of procedure or similar
procedures that the individual states
have adopted kind of modeled on that
that federal procedure I have a question
from Tim in the back hi I'm actually a
member of the guild so thank you meet me
too by the way yes yes why I meant from
within that's perfect perfect well I'm
at a big law firm we're not looking to
change I've no we're not and there's my
questions I find it very compelling what
you're talking about you know what do
you see as the future of law firms and
is there a symbiosis or potential
symbiosis between the law firm model the
provision of personal services I go to
I'm a litigator I have a trial lawyer so
you can you have to go to court if
someone a human being has to go to court
so a symbiosis between law firms
whatever their shape and size is we
could talk about or you can talk about
and services like yours yes I think a
lot of law firms most law firms and
maybe you'll agree with me are set up on
the concept of hourly billing and if you
want to be in good standing at your law
firm if you want to advance it's a
question how many hours are you billing
and the hours are frequently absurd
2000-3000 as December nears and you know
that your bonus is on the line you're
doing everything you can to grab
additional hours that is not a structure
that's conducive to experimentation and
innovation and that i think the exact
kind of structure that you're going to
replicated again after that's history
right why would we change why would you
just said so why would you change and I
agree with you but I think that if we're
going to get sort of fairness or good
access to law things need to change and
so what I see happening in America is
what's happening in again the UK
Australia Canada probably more equity
ownership by non lawyers who are willing
to do things like hey let's invest in
technology and process let's try to
figure out how to make utilization
better because it's smaller law firms
not your law firm sir I'm sure but it's
smaller ones the reason that the rates
are so high is that the average lawyer
is only working about ten percent of the
time if they were working that remaining
ninety percent of the time they wouldn't
have to charge three hundred dollars an
hour they could charge something more
reasonable but instead they're spending
all their time either running after new
clients running down bills or doing
nothing at all so I think that's what
really has to change well thank you both
for an amazing amazing discussion using
two-year lawyers using their background
to help make me for accessible you just
technology and the internet so thank you
guys very much appreciated thank you